[Applause]
you're now live
thank you very much not quite
two o'clock just yet we're just waiting
for the correct minute to take bye
uh
two o'clock well good afternoon
everybody and welcome
to torres district council's committee
of the external overview and scrutiny
welcome to those of you on on youtube
and thank you for the committee for
attending this afternoon
we start with apologies for absence
item number one on the agenda
okay no apologies thank you very much
indeed
can we take a roll call
harding here mary thanks
councillor hawkins yeah here
councillor langford present
councillor leather yeah
you councillor mackenzie
no mary he's not present okay newton
no he's a present either thank you
count pennington i'm here thank you very
much
mary and mr topham
president yeah thank you
apologize mr topham i am
i realize you were there because i spoke
to you earlier thank you for attending
this afternoon all of you
um now i've lost a sheet of paper tom
that
you've given me that i should read it
before every meeting you're a good
committee it's all about raising your
hands etc etc is there any legal bits
that i need to do for the committee
because i think committee are now pretty
old
with all these bits and pieces about the
procedure we need to go through about
raising hands etc
i don't need to do anything from a legal
point of view no that's correct yeah
any questions on that to to tom i
haven't got the extra sheet here okay
we dealt with that one councillor newton
has joined us
oh well done thank you very much indeed
welcome simon
okay we go to agenda item number two
which is the public participation i
gather
is there anybody from members of the
public here this afternoon
thank you right we go to agenda item
number three
declarations of interest um
i think we all have interest here today
but only on a very
keen wish to see the best provided for
play strategy within the torch area
but if there is any interest you know
what the routine is
uh agenda item number four uh agreement
of agenda items part one and two
i have no part two today and i don't
think we'll be discussing anything
afterwards i don't know if the officers
want to raise anything
um that this committee should know about
sean or
janet there no chair nothing from me
nothing at all i'm here chair nothing
from me thank you nothing from you
either okay
so that deals with item number four and
item number five urgent matters brought
forward with the commission of the chair
i have nothing does any on the committee
have anything
or any officer of anything that is
urgent that's come in very very recently
just to say i see that torridge will be
going past a hundred per hundred
thousand probably this week
for crow with virus which will be an
interesting landmark
but uh i don't know if any committee i
don't see any hands going up
no okay right then
we come forward then um to the
item number six which is really the
purpose of the meeting it's an
extraordinary meeting this afternoon
um from looking at this play strategy
um thank you very much for for the
officers for putting the work in for
producing this thank you particularly to
cheryl for leading
um um as lead member for
for community culture and leisure and i
i have had a couple of comments that
adrian put out
um uh councillor langford and
christopher
hawkins honkin um both made responses
have i missed any other responses that
other counselors have made i do
apologize but that's the only two that
um i i've read um if there's others i
apologize to you now
uh anybody indicate they sent something
in in response to
the uh the invite going out to make
response
no yes i think um
when we come to the sort of presentation
and strategy adrian will be able to
explain some of the responses and and
what work we've done
to respond to that okay right now sure
well then then with that
i propose that uh we kick off with you
um
um to set the scene um or is it adrian
either one of you whichever is yeah it's
fine chair thank you
yeah and good afternoon councillors it
um
you know i'm not going to talk for long
because i want to pass over to adrian
whose work it's been actually to to
update the strategy following our last
last meeting where we had quite a good
debate i thought quite an informative
debate
um the the report that covers the
strategy sets the scene for you
it talks about the need uh it talks
about what we're trying to achieve
and and the path that this will follow
should you when you are
happy for it to proceed so it will go
from here to community and resources
for approval so so without further ado i
think it's probably better if we just
uh pass over to adrian he can talk to
you a bit more about what he's been
doing
and then of course in the debate we're
happy to answer any questions you might
have
thank you then adrian please lead us
okay thank you chair um good afternoon
everybody um yeah thank you to all those
who responded with their thoughts um
mainly councillor caught honking
councillor
langford and councillor topham thank you
for your
your input as well um on the on the
updated play area strategy
at the last meeting you would have seen
um what was previously
a play area and open space strategy um
that our maintenance company
had produced before beforehand um just a
bit of an update since then
and we've discussed with with sean and
councillor
kudo hunky and the idea of changing it
um
directing it a bit more to solely a play
area strategy
as our open spaces are sort of well
documented already where within our
other strategies such as green
infrastructure strategy and our plane
pit strategy
um also um members have now seen a big
piece of the audit work that tivoli
did on behalf on our behalf last year
for each play area
i apologize that you hadn't seen that
beforehand i wasn't
aware of it obviously still being fairly
new
um but delving into further i've since
then shared it for everybody to see
hopefully we've now given the document a
little bit more structure
regarding our play areas and some um
clear goals of what we would like to
achieve
in fairly basic forms time scales can
still be discussed
um in terms of any improvements to be
made there'll be there'll be more issues
um to what sort of state in each play
area is now being
um that conditioned survey is now 14
months past
um after the audit since carried out so
um this needs to be updated to be
accurate
we have we've recognized that we need to
concentrate on bigger sites
that our that our local families our
visitors um that use
on their holidays such as victoria park
church fields and possibly car street in
torrington which has already had
a great deal of work um done recently
we've committed to encourage and support
local community groups to take on a lead
in developing play areas
as as ultimately is then as who's going
to
before
it's also to be made clear that the
council has
no additional funding for the
development of the sites and any
financial responsibilities and do not
just lie with the council
moving forward um the idea is
obviously as kind of just mentioned that
strategy cannot commit to any spend
um because that's the role of the of the
cnr and also that there is an intention
for
um an annual conditioned survey um to be
followed by
um a maintenance program so other parts
that included from
any information come through from the
members um a few things
um i've made a note of um it's important
that we
that we update and the audit for the
maintenance team
and changing terms such as satisfactory
when they're still agent urgent works
that need to be carried out at each site
to provide estimates and repairs and for
replacements
for myself to work closely with them to
do that to build on that relationship
so they're all kind of singing from the
same sort of hymn sheet
including development of void areas as
best as possible
excuse me it's recognized we need to
make better connections with the housing
developers for what's expected for
maintenance of the sites
and what happens at the end of
maintenance term for any news site
and um regularly update the committee
uh every three or six months on
developments
and then as shawn mentioned earlier with
recommendations that
any additions taken out of the meeting
and from members that were sent in and
any typos
to be corrected for this committee to
recommend
the place play area strategy for cnr
committee
as soon as possible to discuss the
financial implications and how we move
forward
for me thank you thank you very much
indeed adrian
okay so now we come forward to discuss
the document as a committee
and uh what i'd like to do
just try to keep the structure to it is
is break it into
four areas if i could um first of all i
just wanted some overall
view of the document because if you look
at the recommendations this is going to
go forward to cnr
um for for adoption at the earliest
opportunity that's in the recommendation
we're seeking
um from the report and what i'd like to
do first of all is to have an overview
of the document
then look at pages 9-29
and then go on to the uh
30 to 112 and then just a brief comment
on
what goes into the appendices um after
page 112.
so can we open up and have a discussion
first of all a general overall view of
how you feel the document is coming
through
committee please
or put your hands up at once because i
might be talking all the afternoon
otherwise
okay we have counselor leather
well i'll start the ball rolling chair
thank you
councillor this is a much better
document than we had previously
uh i'd seen all this um
the condition of all the play spaces
that we've got all 36 of them i think
i'd seen that before i do disagree with
some of what's in that because
i think most of them for me are probably
unsatisfactory
uh some are classed as good when i would
have said they're only satisfactory but
that's by the way the main thing is what
we're going to do about our play areas
and for me the first thing or one thing
i think we ought to do
having read through this report and it
is a good report
a bit long-winded in places a bit
bureaucratic in places but it is a good
report
then i'm dead keen that
as far as the play areas go we offer
them to the town of parish councils
the ones that are in their areas i'd
like to see if
town and parish councils want to take on
these
and i know further on i think it's on
the
stage three in the report talking about
asset transfers
and i read that almost to read we're
more concerned about making money out of
the sites if we hand them over
to town and parish councils rather than
letting town and parish councils take
them on
at a peppercorn price or rent
and let them find the funding to improve
them
i'm not happy with the long-winded
approach 2031
talking about 10 years to make our
player is excellent for me he's not good
enough
we should be aiming a much shorter
period than that at making them
excellent
uh whether we want to keep all of them
or not
but i do think we need to involve early
town and parish councils that have got
play areas
in their parishes and towns but i'll
leave it at that for now chair
thank you very much indeed counselor
leather
uh okay another uh your hand there sean
you got your hand up
thank you i just wanted to um to
respond to councillor leather and
reassure him that we're not
uh we're not into money making from our
play estates it's not that
the asset transfers just it's sort of
professional jargon
as much as anything else it doesn't mean
that we're
we're looking to add value and pass them
on at a profit that's
certainly not the intention and and i
think that the
strategic intent is to open the dialogue
with our communities
parishes and towns and where possible
and where it's most beneficial
and where practical i think is actually
a good one to put as well because of
certain instances it isn't practical
for for that to happen but where it is
practical
um to discuss with our towns parishes
how they might have a more active role
in management
even ownership of play spaces in certain
instances so
yes i think that's that's the intent of
the document
thank you is that a good answer for of
your other well
yeah that's fine but the thing is a lot
of the parishes as you know
chair have already provided them
something with a little and they've got
an excellent play area
that the parish council provided the
people of the area provided
but i do think initially we want to see
what parish and town councils are
interested in in which play areas
that they've got in their area because
that's going to depend on
on the responses from them as to whether
we'd
continue to look to improve all of them
or only some of them
and hand the others over to the parent
parish and 10 councils
and i mean i mean hand them over not
like happened with the park at western
oregon torres made a hundred thousand
out of northern town council for that
one okay
thank you council heather councillor
ford
yeah um i must
i must admit here it's taken me not to
do this but um i'm actually
green basically i think come to leather
and that to be fair i think
we are here with one thing in mind to
actually make the best provision
possible for the youth of college as a
whole
and if we're not that's a bad thing um
and again there's no point going on
about history we
have got a lot of play areas that are
not good
um and we don't have to be specific
which ones are better than others you
know that's
pointless it's about actually trying to
improve and yeah seek
excellence or close to it um that's what
we all want
before i go on i would like to thank uh
councillor langford and cole hunking
because i'm a great believer
irrespective of political um
leanings or whatever that's irrelevant
it is about
working together and using the skills we
got at college and both of these
councillors are obviously very unfair
very good in this area and i commend
them for that and their effort
um it's interesting to hear
and i do go with that and i would also
like to say that
someone's been in a new post it's works
orders adrian i'm very
you know very known to be critical but
i'm also very equal and praised where
it's tuned i think reporter
done in short note is is very very good
and you know we're going to be
nitpicking everything can be better
you know and that might be the case but
mentioning church fields
obviously uh you're right because we are
a tourist um
area uh as well and you know when this
cover
is over i mean covey's over towards them
it's gonna be even more important
which is why church fields is close to
my art obviously because it is both a
car park in a play area not
not a bloody campsite sorry better
language but you know
we have got um in you know we have got
to play on that um
but all small areas are very important
and i do think historically
that developers have walked away which
they have
however again that's history we can't
shape history we can talk about today
and tomorrow
now going forwards because liver is
absolutely right
and we have actually got to try to
transfer without making profit
um where necessary to paris and 10
councils that's
that's critical but what i would also
say
where possible um these
parishes and town councils can't be
expected to take over something that
is in really really bad order so
there is a bit of oldness on us at least
to get things up to scratch which is no
church feels
excellent other than the two little kids
swings that's been missing for five
months i do want
back and i've actually mentioned that
because things tend to go away and never
come back
but i think we want to be positive here
because it is you know history's history
we can't influence that
we can do better um and we don't need to
you know be points going about which is
better than other ones or whatever
we have got big issues as is most
different councils
but let's try to be positive and i'd say
council lovers made some good points and
i think
nearly all countries all agree with that
and where we can have working with paris
and town councils that's definitely the
way to go
thank you christopher do you feel that
the overall view of the document is is a
good one and a good base to start from
our our basic discussion here
yeah definitely because in fairness
coastal level was actually right to be
critical to start with um
because it wasn't that growing and you
know this document maybe
it could be could be better hey it could
be a lot worse i think the officer
and the um time scales and an excellent
job and you know like that note it it's
because you know i'm
i'm always fresh to criticize mate when
it needs to be criticized but
no this is pretty damn good it's a good
start
thank you very much indeed councillor
ford uh coaster mckenzie
well i hope everybody's gonna be able to
hear me i'm in the car on mobile data
um yeah it's all like trying to squeeze
this between work
um yeah um going back to what uh
counselor
ford was saying about the towns and
councils level about the towns and
parishes picking it up
um obviously billy ford have got a lot
of um
play parks in their area i know that we
um discuss
that um other benefit councillors will
know as well that we put a sum of money
aside and i think that's a match funded
from the bridge trust to be able to
look after some of our play parks but
that money's not going to go very far if
we take on all of them in benefit
um and obviously um there's the state of
repair of a lot of them
is not great um so i think that we need
to make it attractive for the
the the towns and parishes for uh to
take it on uh
and do them up uh to the best possible
standards so they take them on
you know because if you take them on in
a state of disrepair
nobody's gonna want to do that so if we
repair them
uh and then give them over um
i think that that will probably be a
goal because there's a lot of
rural parishes that you know
perhaps have got you know only one play
park that they need to and then you know
their preset may be
uh okay to deal with that or you know
maybe some council of grant money could
be used for it but um
biddeford's got a lot of play parks and
i know that persimmon homes
are approaching billy for town council
at the moment to take on
some of the uh play parks that they have
um in in the easter areas so
yeah if we can make it attractive for
the parishes to take them on
i think that they would probably go with
it and yeah they
they've got to wear with all the draw
down some extra funding i think so
yeah okay you you thank you very much
for your comment there coach mckenzie
uh christopher haynes had his hand up
i'm not a member of the committee but
i'm glad to see you this afternoon
christopher haynes thank you chair thank
you for letting me speak
yeah i um fully endorse what the other
last two speakers have said about
transferring to
local councils um at north and we've
successfully taken on
um play areas and have improved them
considerably
i hope um taking on a specific thing
that council ford said about church
fields that's a very well used
and very important play area
particularly in the summer
and it's very important it's fully
equipped and please
i've written to mike crocker pointing
out the swings two swings have been
missing
for quite some time on the general level
as
on the climate issue and biodiversity i
know
there's um i think that close to nature
in the uh
list of um important aspects for play
areas
and i would sort of urge us to do
more planting if possible trees
wildflowers whatever which sort of
relate children to their environment
i think that's very important thank you
yeah on on the recycling right there's
no no
there's um i think it's nice if we can
possibly put in
sort of jolly recycling bins yeah play
play areas where
mothers and children can put
cans and whatever and again this draws
children into the importance
right environment if possible thank you
chair
thank you councillor haynes uh
councillor newton member of the
committee
uh thank you very much um
i think as this is a strategy
um we we need to to to state fairly
firmly within it or the the document
needs to state quite
firmly what is our preferred policy
from a council point of view and
and then it needs to justify that um
by saying we want to save money i is is
not a justification
um i don't think would be an acceptable
justification at least it may be
justifiable to some but
uh i don't think we would get anywhere
but i think it probably needs a little
bit of
historical analysis to look at those
areas where play parks have been within
town or parish ownership or stewardship
to then do a comparison to see if
actually
they are better cared for
kept more up to date better looked after
better respected
um and also the ability for
the the local community or local
authority there
to be able to react more quickly when
something goes wrong it needs repair or
update
um so i think and in that preferred
policy perhaps
you know we need to list incentives
as to why we are suggesting that it
it if that is the ultimate um
recommendation that it that these
should be passed over to town and parish
which personally i believe
is good um because ultimately
you know one can say if the work's been
done we can say that there is a
historical precedent
that actually these areas these public
areas are better looked after
better respected um better cared for and
therefore there is greater availability
of higher quality play equipment
um for longer time if the local
community
have ownership of it um and i would
suggest
that only where there is a
site that potentially has
development potential that we place some
form of overage clause on it otherwise
one would see that
all of these sites have been transferred
at nil cost i wouldn't have thought that
it's fairly churlish to try to uh uh
because we are we are passing
responsibility to a to another authority
um but i think you get a better result
and having looked through
and seen comments on um some
which are in local ownership um it seems
that the outcome is a lot better than
if it's done as group group ownership by
ourselves certainly i have a parish
who have recently put in a new play area
which they funded through um
grants and fundraising
and they look after that very carefully
they cherish it
they treat it as their own um and um
i think that's a a lot to taking
ownership with a small o
um is very important with these things
because then the community actually buys
into it much more
okay but i think preferred policy we
need to understand that and that
that policy would to transfer all of
those
that one statement in itself
would be a full council decision but
surely presumably because it's actually
transferring of quite a a major um a
group of little assets and secondly um
uh it's actually a change of directional
policy because we're saying we're
getting out of
revision of this and there's there seems
to be some consensus coming through from
from
the committee you know about the the
transfers
and how that should work and what our
policy should be in that direction
um can i just ask you do you view the
basic document just as the first
questions
christian newton as an acceptable base
for us to start from from our
discussions that's what i was trying to
drive out at the beginning
sorry yeah sorry yeah i think a lot of
what you're saying comes into our second
part which is going to be looking at
pages 9-29
about putting policies in places where
we want to go actually um
yeah i i apologize i'm a bit bit bit
bitter bit ahead of myself yeah um we
are distracted
in a way by the fact that the play area
condition survey is attached to the back
of it
because that that's actually that's an
absolute
historic addendum to it one almost needs
to rip that off and put it aside
uh and we're just looking at this what's
in front of that
um because that's a new material a new
work that we that we're interested in
okay yeah thank you uh
sean you want to come back sean kearney
yes thank you chair yeah
the couple of points there um in terms
of
uh working with towns and parish
councils it i
i think you know like i said before that
it's it's absolutely the intent
because uh we have i think
spread ourselves too thin in play and
not concentrated our involvement in
those areas where we really can make an
impact
and instead try to do a little bit which
probably wasn't enough
in every play area that we own and so
the the intention is that we get back to
concentrating on our main play sites are
the ones that you know we recognize
where we can have the greatest impact
ones that are probably of scale that
make them
relevant to us and then work with our
towns and parishes now
in every instance it's not going to be
affordable i i would imagine
to make a rolls-royce play area before
you transfer it
i think we might have to be practical
about how we work
with our parishes and community groups
because they have access to funding that
we don't necessarily have access to
to to facilitate those improvements and
then think about transfer so that's just
a point
of sort of procedure there really i
don't think we're going to be able to
say that we can do up every place
play site and then transfer it out
because we simply won't have the funds
for that
okay um but the but the principle is is
sound
um i i got absolutely no problem at all
with putting in some case studies of
success you know we've
we've got some from around the district
to where we could
show that how these practices have
worked and they've been really
successful that i think that's probably
a good idea
um the reason that the uh the
the condition survey is appended is
because um in our last discussions it
was asked that it was
um again if you as council you know
county committee would prefer
that it won't then say so and we can we
can produce a strategic document without
that
i i think i i'm tending to agree that
that's more of a
management tool than a strategic guide
um
but yeah so so yes that just a couple of
points there
to come back to council's points thank
you very much uh councillor harding
yeah thank you chair um a couple of my
um parishes uh in my board uh
um are um running their own as well as
uh having um
a couple of uh um from from torridge um
and it's it's not easy for the ones that
are running it because uh
they are limited to who can repair it
and uh
and it costs a lot of money and they're
always looking looking to
find out you know what they should do in
that so i think you know like
if we did hand over we they would need
to have someone
see them through the you know the the
the
you know maintenance and things like
that give them some pointers and that
but i think it'd be a good idea um i'm
just
just disappointed that you're aware you
haven't got a play area as such we've
only got a small one in the school
um and we never never have that as uh
a play area and uh we are we are poorer
for it so
you know it is important so you know i
think it's um
you have a fantastic village hall there
at the woodring
yeah there's there's some good points um
you know basically you know
as all places they're growing
everywhere's growing so yeah
you know so it's something that we need
to get sorted and push on so yeah
you know i i take on board all right
what john has said and what that
all the other council has been saying
you know right no then
just to move us all we've got chrysler
ford and council langford so councillor
ford first
uh thanks joe again i'll try to be
briefly i've already had one uh
one bite of the apple um just locally
anchor part was taken over
opposite um well i live by apple or
school
um that's done quite well in general i
think all agreeing
bottom up approach is better because
it's about local ownership therefore you
get
i think more respect more involvement
um definitely where you go however
clemson isn't spot on
um i'm not here suggesting for one
moment
that we give over staff in fact it might
be better
rather than sort of freo miso but
peppercorn or whatever
we've got um you know i'm not trying to
be seen to make profit but also we can't
give away assets
just for the sake of it i think we all
agree with that because we are you know
we all are responsible for the taxpayer
at large
um so i think we need to look at that
and also i do agree with sean
you're absolutely right in an ideal
world and i was only making
a suggestion and that's where you go get
a balance
because we haven't got the resource
to make every uh play area brilliant
and then pass it on he's absolutely
right he's living in the real world we
all
are you know let's be brutally honest
therefore what i'm simply saying
is each case on its merits
this don't be greedy which i ain't
saying we are but you know it's not all
about
money but we must also protect ourselves
from do i say if we did actually
transfer
it would actually have to be a clause or
we do at least over the peppercorn rent
because i'm not a fool
we can't go giving away something that
next year's down the line might be
very desirable or even built on because
uh sadly we know that things times do
change and with that i'll leave it
okay thank you very much langford
thanks very much chair i don't want to
repeat stuff that i've already
put in the email i sent but thank you
for
uh your comments and for councillor
ford's comments um i just want to say
looking at the overall strategy
um i i feel slightly uncomfortable about
the asset transfer but i think that's
probably because i
i don't know enough about it or how it
would work
i just want to make sure if it does
happen that it is successful and happens
in the right cases and happens
quickly enough um i think from
um i think looking at strategy overall
though in brief
maybe i'd like a little bit more about
the working group
and how um how that will
work um outside of the situation of the
asset transfer so in other words things
like how often there'll be inspections
and
and where work is needed how quickly it
can be done
because i think we all know that
wherever there is damage to parks or
things get closed down um how quickly
that can have a demoralizing effect on
the community
so the speed that things can be repaired
or replaced is really important
and i need to know a bit more but
obviously that could come up later
about if there could be any sort of
ongoing
maintenance um budget um outside of the
capital system but
that's fine for now thanks very much
okay thank you very much
i mean just picking up one comment there
chris langford i mean you mentioned your
email about the play
champion and you said i'm not sure how
this will operate
um and that you said the the working
group could involve
a paid employee counselor if i got the
right part of your email there from
that point of view where that's
referring to the issues you're raising
oh no that was just a query about
exactly i think it said a member of
staff i think that was the wording of
the play
champion and i was just i i was just
inquiring did that mean
i didn't mean that they should be paid i
just meant does that mean um a member of
someone who already works for choice
district council
or does it mean that it would be a
counsellor it was just a question
i mean my query about the play champion
is just that
um you know it's great great if it if it
actually has a bit of clout
um but if it if it um if it's just a
gimmick then it's not worth having if
you see what i mean
thank you thank you uh councillor honkin
um i just want to thank adrian for all
of the hard work that he's
put into it because he was throwing in
he joined us not that long ago i think
he's done a really good job
on it um and i'd like it to
i wrote in an email i'd like a lot more
emphasis on the communication within the
council because i think in the past
that's been lacking
um so between like the planning
department property and procurement
and leisure services as well so if we
could have that
as a regular thing and then feed back to
this committee
with what is happening with the
different play areas i think that would
be really
beneficial and then we can sort of feed
into
what our priorities are and find out
where we are with the asset management
asset transfers but i do agree with
what's been said
and i think if you do look around at the
local play areas the ones that are run
by the community so by the parish
councils they do tend to be looked after
and they do manage to raise the funds to
have a better play area at the end of
the day
and that's what we want we all want
better facilities for our communities
and i think that's the best that looks
to be the best way to sort of get there
realistically um so obviously we will
need to
improve them to some extent if we want
them to take them on i expect
right that does sound like a good
starting point and then see what we're
left with
and what improvements need to be made
and
go from there but communication within
the council would be a
big thing for me because
i think that's needed thank you for your
comment
um can i ask um jamie mckenzie's how
he's out before sean kearney
but sean you maybe want to respond to to
uh counselor carlo honkin
yeah absolutely if that's okay with uh
chris mckenzie i'm just gonna let sean
respond there
if that's possible please i mean i i i
completely
agree with some of um with some of
cancer cotton
king's are about communications and i
think that's what
if you like steve has tried to achieve
with reorganization and bringing many of
these
place related functions services into
one
area and i think hopefully we know that
in our current organization structure
we'll have a better dialogue between
the service managers for those different
functions that enable us to be a bit
more joined up on that so that's so
that's one point there
i think that's quite positive quite i
think we can manage those things much
better
the other point was around there is a
prescribed process for community asset
transfer
we have an adopted process for that um
the details are on our website and that
basically sets out
the the procedure for transferring out
assets to community groups and
harsh councils and the like and i think
finally the point was
around the ongoing management and
monitoring of delivery against the
strategy now normally what happens is
you'd adopt a strategy that strategy
would then inform
how we pull together our business plans
our service delivery plans
and those are generally monitored by
internal ons through the qbr
so we might be into
internal monitoring the progress of the
delivery of this strategy rather than
external but that's a that's that'll be
a point for you to threshold with
councillor watson on
sure mr chairman so you're very much
indeed
thank you mackenzie
um yeah i was just wondering um you know
we're talking about these assets that we
could be
transferring etc um do we own all of the
all of the assets or are we custodian of
some of them because
obviously back in what was it 74 with
the um
when the borough councils uh transferred
a lot of their
assets to the district council um you
know there was a lot of custodianship so
do we actually own all of these parks um
or you know
or some of them we're just custodians of
that we can just transfer them back at
no cost
sean can you answer that question so i
think probably stacy will be chomping at
the bit to answer this one to be honest
but i think
it's um
[Laughter]
stacy here this afternoon he is yeah
yeah stacy sorry
yes right we were on standards this
morning so we are on to to
play area this afternoon i don't know
which is most funny really but there we
go
stacy stacy thank you sean
i'm sure you could have adequately
answered for you chair but i think when
the government reorganization happened
council mackenzie those assets were
actually transferred to torridge
um so the one the areas in this play
strategy are ones that are directly
owned by torridge
if that that helps okay so
thank you thank you for that can i just
ask um would uh chuckly fort be one of
uh those areas that we're we're
considering
uh chair um and is is that owned by
torridge
is there are they custodians of that i'm
just thinking of these water
area can we come back to that one a
little later on we're looking really
just to start with to approve the
overall strategy here
okay um um
but yeah certainly i i approve of the
overall strategy it seems to be a good
document to start with yeah okay i might
have to leave
very shortly i'm afraid chair but um
i'll text you that if i
if i may you certainly can thank you
very much for stopping i hope you're in
a nice
safe place at the present moment and go
from there okay
uh soon uh hang on
uh independent member mr topham please
thanks chair
um yeah the document as a whole
the rationale seems very sad the aims
are good the aspirations
are admirable i felt the the sort of
pathways to getting things
done the sort of implementation side of
it could have been clearer
and it sounds from the discussion that
that maybe the council should be making
clear that perhaps they're going to hang
on to flagship
playgrounds and start a process
a gradual managed process of transfer to
local parish councils and town councils
and be a bit clearer about that process
for what for whatever reasons that is
going to happen
so that that seemed important a bit more
clarity there
i think to have some some case examples
as sean suggested is an excellent idea
but what seemed missing to me when i was
going through the
the review of the evaluation of the
various playgrounds
is any sense of how much it might cost
to bring them up to the required
standard or even just to maintain them
on a regular basis
and i think if if the implementation
strategy
involves discussions with parish and
town councils
then to give people some idea of the
costs that they might be in for if they
take it on i think would be very helpful
and would help them to sort of plan and
and after all funding is not easy to
come by at all
so to at least uh offer people some
sense of how much it cost
and i'm assuming what would also be part
of that would be
assurance of support and guidance from
officers
to to help them with fundraising
[Music]
just picking up your comment there uh mr
topham
um i did notice on page 26 that over the
last six years torrid has invested more
than 410
yeah i saw that but i couldn't find
anything in past
budget specifically about i just
wondered if sean or
adrian could um comment on on on
um that figure there that runs out at 70
000 pound a year but
obviously it's very difficult to um
allocate it to which
parks have received the most and which
is not and uh um
um i i try to find it hard but how much
is torridge actually spending per year
on its play areas
at the present moment it does vary chair
because it
so that that that money would have been
would have come out of like a responsive
repairs budget
rather than a dedicated play budget it's
not necessarily allocated or easy to
allocate that to exactly
which swing seat was replaced in
biddeford
or which roundabout was replaced in
torrington you know because
that that tends to happen in a
responsive basis and
we don't budget for it that way um
moving forward
uh we currently have uh obviously a
responsive repairs budget in our in our
property team so adrian redwood looks
after that one and we maintain
uh the player is on a responsive basis
like that in terms of improvement
and reinstatement there's money in the
capital program i believe it's
we're looking at it early on i think
it's 250 000 pounds but that's spread
over a number of years
um so it's not if you look at that we
don't hold a vast amount of money for
the improvement of play spaces
um we we do sort of manage and maintain
as quickly on the low level things as we
possibly can but when it comes to the
replacement
of of pieces of equipment we're often
seeking funding seeking 106 contribution
so it's not always our direct money
that's going into the replacement some
of these facilities some of it
is brought in from elsewhere okay thank
you sean for that answer question newton
uh thank you chair just um really
um following up from what mr toppin had
just said um
and having uh um said kind words to
start with i i
i would comment as a communication
document um i think this document needs
to be
clearer and more concise um as somebody
who's reading it
where i want to extract the fact be
given the detail
laid out in a way that i can then
formulate
a view and come up with my own personal
decision
it's not laid out in that way it's too
soft there's
too much dropping of other cut and paste
for instance i take you to page
twenty overall page 22 where we have the
design for play
and then we have a long list 10 10 items
listed on page 23
which are all very good worthy things
they're actually a statement of the
obvious
um and it it's too soft for
that can go as necessary as an annex or
whatever i think it needs to be a bit
more punchy
um but there's a there's a there's a lot
of pretty soft wordage in it
which is i wouldn't expect to see
in a policy or strategy document where
i'd expect to see it being much more
cutting to to the fact and likewise
for instance as mr topham raised again
you know is is our policy that we're
gonna
we're gonna split this and we're gonna
end up with
centralized sites that we want to retain
but we want to actually
transfer everything else therefore
to to do so and to bring them to a
satisfactory level
before we could contemplate transferring
them a prediction of a cost
roughly what's it going to cost us
because in order to make decisions on
these sort of things
one needs sadly to know the figures that
are attached to them because that is the
thing that actually
constrains us all so i would ask for it
to be
a bit more punchy based more on fact and
detail
and point me more clearly towards
what is it that you're wanting me to
actually evaluate and
and then form an opinion on um and i
find it a bit soft in that sense
um so i hear you're standing a lot of
hard work in it i'm not getting at that
i i you know my question yeah
christopher hudson
thank you very much uh mr chairman other
members
i know i'm not a member of the committee
uh but i do have experience
of um park acquisition very recently
but i wanted to offer some words of just
reassurance
with regard to um the conditions that
are laid down
for people who are have acquired a park
and that in the deed of transfer it is
very clearly stated that the land will
be kept in perpetuity
for recreational purposes and will not
be used for anything else
so um that is a comfort i think
to those who were concerned that should
uh in subsequent years a town and parish
council
realize the value of their site and
allocate it for some other use
that would not be allowed so it's
assurance on that fact and i thought i
would share that with you today thank
you
thank you very much sean kearney
thank you chad um just to come back on
cancer newton's point
i just wondering i i i completely um
accept the the want for something clear
and concise so okay
i get that i wonder whether uh rather
than taking out some of the information
that
was described as wordy but i i think
he's intended to provide some context
some background some
sort of holistic view of these sorts of
things
i wonder whether the inclusion of an
executive summary or something like that
might
help to sort of summarize the key
strategic
um intentions just a question really for
councillor newton
i uh in in indeed sean thank for that
yet i would
i would have assumed anyhow that when
this comes up as a final document
that it would have an executive summary
at
front of it anyway um one would imagine
is
h9 has made space for an executive
summary to go in
and i think sure caller honking made
comment in her email
um about the the facing of that um
executive summary as well by the way
so yeah that would certainly help thank
you
okay has it got no further blue hands i
mean
one or two things coming through there i
mean a very favorable um
view of the amount of work that's gone
in so thank you to the officers
uh for the work that's gone into to this
document but one or two issues come out
it's about clarity
and it's about the issues of of whether
it's local or
or or uh centralized view of as kind of
force says bottom up i think it was um
approach to the uh to to to doing this
um at least we begin with a document
here and i think we may touch on
that central discussion though and if
there's anybody who disagrees
but can we just state right now because
they're clear that
the overall document provides us with
the base to move
forward to look at the situation
of where we are with our play strategy
we can make one or two small adjustments
as we go through and we can try to ask
for clearer
more positive concise strategies as we
go through the pages
but we have a base document here that
none of us would want to see
and not go forward
nobody's hand going up so we've got that
consensus i hope
good no blue hands whatsoever i got a
green anton with a tick
what does that mean
yes i got a yes there there you go
hey we got to take the votes is by a
green tick with a yes and we may be
quicker at meetings from that point of
view okay so so we've got those
sort of sentiments coming through sean
adrian are you happy to work on those
feelings have come through from this
part of the discussion can i get a
reaction from both of you from
and i think it's for us counselors just
to really think about you know where the
strategy is actually going through
has been said i mean where is our
direction here
um uh and i think we'll come into that
in our second part now so i want to go
through
pages 9 to 29 if i can and
picking up each page as we go through
them basically um
and i think sherry i mean uh sure caller
honking you made a really um
telling point i think in your email
about asking ken
james to be involved in in this front
page can you lead us here just this
present moment
i don't know if um councillor james has
been sent the
um draft or not but i thought it would
be good to get his view as leader
and hopefully his endorsement of the
strategy and the focus on
play areas within torridge i don't know
if um other counsellors would agree
well i would certainly agree i i am just
a little concerned about page nine
because i i
i mean when i see um i think when you
can
all sign together equally at the bottom
i think it involves the
joined up council um and you know i
certainly would like to see a joint
statement if necessary from
our chief exec and our leader our leader
or chief exec
each way because that is quite sometimes
a political argument
very soon um but certainly i mean i just
look at that front page
and i take what the council call hook
has said in in the email
um and could we do the executive summary
from that point of view i know when i
read a lot of documents
i get past page eight and read the
executive summary and i don't go much
further and i think
that executive summary sometimes is the
most important pages to any document so
i would certainly like to see a lot of
work done in that direction
can i come sorry chad can i jump in on
that yeah certainly you can
the executive i'm worried about
executive
summary getting tangled up with
endorsements by the chief executive
or the the lead member um
the executive summary is is is not their
spin on it that the
executive summary is a an extraction of
key
fact um distilled down to
hopefully a a very short read um
and so i think it needs to sit away from
the the endorsements by the chief
executive and the lead member and to be
quite honest
uh i'm cautious about endorsements
because um
if if if um if if it wasn't any good
then they wouldn't be endorsing it
anyway so
i mean it's a it's a pretty state
statement of the obvious in a way but um
um
so yeah executive summary absolutely but
that needs to come
at the beginning of the
strategy rather than um
somehow linked to endorsements i would
have thought
personally okay i
hear your comment so uh how would you
put that page nine
and as as the front leading
picture because everybody pays top price
for advertising to be inside the front
cover et cetera et cetera
what would you put in there counselor
newton
um i'm looking at page nine now
specifically
yeah yeah i've got you um
i mean you know if there if there is a
um
i mean this is this is an important
district-wide um
policy um personally i i would have
um i would have thought that um
two i'm just sorry thinking on my feet
endorsements
endorsement although i've sat down um
endorsements
typically come towards the end of a
document i i i'm not sure whether we
once wanting to whatever the council
policy is but
i'm a bit strange to um be seeing the
chief executive and the leader
um putting sort of their comments um
before once actually even read the
document um
well i just look at the way i mean i've
accomplished another year there
um listening i mean you've seen the
local plan and remind me if i'm correct
in this
but when the local plans have gone out
both the 2011 and the last ones gone out
um it was uh signed by um
uh kaiser whitaker and counts and they
had a paid service at the time
um and they signed actually inside the
front cover to
to show that it was a united effort um
am i correct in that
uh council another i think it was i
think it
i think it was signed by both the
leaders of north denver district council
and porridge district council i'm fine
by the okay yeah
yes sir perhaps i'm coming back and
saying that i'm not looking for
statements at the front i'm just looking
for it to be signed by the leader and
the chief executive
um which which binds both halves of the
council together
um but we don't need sort of individual
statements because that's
i don't think that's necessary other
than you know they're signing it off as
as an official document okay so we'll
pick up councillor caller pumpkins
um email um about getting the leader
in here and we don't know if ken james
has seen the uh
the document of the present moment but
again i following that model
um i certainly would like to see your to
give it the strength
that the leader of the council actually
puts their name to this document
and i i if there's i got two blue hats
here from that point of view but
certainly would like to see
that strength given to the document uh
councillor
chair i just have a look in the local
plan yeah the north devlin torres local
plan
after the forward it's signed by both
leaders dez braille if you're north
devon
and james whitaker's leader there's
nobody else that
no officer has signed it no officer
signed it so so that gave the strength
that it was a a
council led document
um whereas i i'm just slightly concerned
that it is the chief exec
has been put in there on this on page
nine sean kearney has got this blue and
uh hand no
all right report those before yeah you
carry on
yeah just briefly i think we're getting
bogged down in pontification here
actually
uh council newton is uh right however
and basically
let's make it very simple the process of
this strategy is going to be discussed
by us
formulated by us then go to cnr then
hopefully endorsed by a full council
down the line when we actually have got
a hardcore
copy that's you know they're ready to go
yeah then it is right
and proper in my opinion that both the
lead officer chief whatever you want to
call him and the
uh lead counselor um should actually
sign it they don't have to make any
view on it or whatever that's you know
that's our role to do that
um but i think we're actually wasting a
lot of time here actually
on sort of pontificating i'm gonna say
waffle
but okay i hear a comment thank you uh
coacher ford
uh sean carney thank you chair i mean
i'm not i'm not sure it's but it it's
particularly important if there's any
officer in door
what's minute i think that's just a
suggestion for your to
think about i see my name's listed there
i'm i'm not particularly
uh you know i don't they don't need to
know what i think about it
we wouldn't be we wouldn't be here today
if we weren't happy that it was the
right
type of thing to put to you as
councillors um
maybe it's a joint forward there's an
absence of a forward and then maybe
maybe that's what it is maybe we just
need a a sort of
an introduction to the document that
comes from from the lead
leader in chief exec okay
okay i mean i'm happy with that um i
don't know the other committee feels
councillor haynes yeah hey joe i mean
just as an observer i
it seems natural to me that the lead
member for play strep for play
and leisure were to write the forward
really
yeah looking for check and coaching
um yeah i'm quite happy with whatever
whatever people want
yeah piece of nominee okay
then then picking up the comment it was
i was following off from your email
character caller honking that came
through
which i had a bit of feeling for um
bearing in mind that that i i would like
to see the counselor
at some point at the top of the page
there basically that was my point of
view
um from that side um and we
move on um uh i i
certainly i think a counselor should be
somewhere on the top
or at least sharing the front page
basically okay
any blue lights there blue hands
okay then we go through
pages 9-29 this is really getting back
now to the direction we're going in
um and and how we actually put this
policy uh
picking up the comments that we had in
the earlier stages um
and i just wonder how we can work it
around it um uh to to achieve
what is best for youngsters with the
finite resources that we have
and who actually owns these sites etc
how we put it into being
um let's go through the pages
and see where they go to because you
were the first one
to mention about um the the transfers of
one thing or another
and how should those be worded because i
hear what you're saying from from
northern point town council point of
view and what has caused northern town
council
and i got to take off my chairmanship
hat now and just be an ordinary member
just for a moment
but i'm in a ward that doesn't have any
of these uh
areas in them um and i would be i can
hear some of my
members or my residents saying to me oh
they're selling assets that should be
gone into a situation
and you've got to balance that with the
situation of uh
achieving the very best for our children
and and that's where i'm just
slightly concerned and picking up
country newton's direction about policy
and now we actually get that policy in
place because that's a huge discussion
about the balance between resources and
providing
what we want to do for our children and
we're trying to capture that
into a direction that is more appointed
clearer
uh of how we want to come out and i
would like to to see how we actually
achieve that
in these pages coaster leather well
thanks chair well because it's it's it's
simple it's not complicated
and i've been making a few notes one
thing we need
is a a specific play space transfer
strategy
i know sean mentioned we have an asset
transfer strategy but if you look at it
it's it's in there it's a bit
long-winded and
legalistic and too official we need a
specific place
transfer strategy picking up on on the
uh on page 11 there because one page by
page
on the financials i think we ought to be
putting in there
maintenance budget under the financials
and i think when we go to the budget set
in this
autumn we need a budget for maintenance
because
even if we're going to be transferring
some of these play areas eventually
in the meantime we do need a maintenance
budget
specifically i don't want to dip into
the pot that sean mentioned adrian has
um renewals and that because frankly we
haven't been renewing much at all
i i failed to see how we've been able to
spend 410
000 in six years because when you look
through the
the report of all the various players
you look at the number
where a piece of equipment's been
shifted and never replaced
and there's pic photographs showing on
many of them
and the flagship one which is at the
start
of there the ridgeway drive play area
that we took over from toys
northern took over from torridge
northern let it
be stripped bearer of equipment it was
sat there with a horrible rubber matting
and the fencing rotting around it it was
going to be
the fencing was going to be cleared by
troj and it was just going to be left
like that
so we decided because there was a awful
lot of housing with young children in
the area
that we would we would go out and
consult with the people in the media
area which we did
and asked them what they wanted there
and did they want
would they support northern town council
take it in which we did
now there are various grants it's true
that parish and town councils can access
that torres district
council can't but i was and i hadn't
realized it but
when you think councillor harding
mentioned woolsery wolves has not got a
player
that's dreadful when you think of all
the new housing that's going on there
over the last few years and they've got
not got a decent play area
so i do think another point i've made is
reinforcement of negotiations
with develop developers for a better
standard of provision
because they've been let off the hook
for far too many years
in what they've been providing but the
actual player is we've got at the moment
parish councils as northern have done
can apply for
public works loans and spread it over a
period
so they needn't think they've got to
jack the precept up to
an unaffordable level you know we're
looking to
finance the part we've taken over at
westwood or over 50 years because it's
it's into the future it's not just for
the current generation
of users it's for the future and the
same with the player is
and as councillor hudson mentioned there
is that protection and
we couldn't develop it if we want to
because the agreement is it
we can't do it's got to be in perpetuity
it's a play area and a park
and the same would apply to any
transfers to parish councils but i
wouldn't want to frighten off
a parish council by saying oh it's going
to cost you 30 40
000 pounds to take it over and to
improve it
and at the same time apart from maybe
some basic
safety things i don't i don't think tori
should be paying if if a parish council
is going to take it over
but they should be transferred virtually
at no cost because
people talk about these being assets for
the district council they're not assets
they're depreciating play areas that
aren't worth anything as they are
and much better that they're given to
like a local group even not necessarily
a parish council
who would take it on and would maintain
it much better that is a real asset then
and uh that's my thinking but everybody
else have this [ __ ]
shawn's got his hand up john's got his
hand up yes sean
sean carney no no surprise on your face
there counselor leather
no it's um
i think that the the community asset
transfer like i say perhaps it's a it's
a document that frightens people off and
perhaps it's all of those things but
it's it's a document that that accords
with the localism act
the local government act and there's
legislative states will step in if i'm
wrong and there's legislative basis for
much of this
ability to transfer and the process you
need to
follow to be able to do it so i i think
we
we need to just help our communities
through that process i don't don't get
me wrong
i think the process is like the process
is for a reason
maybe without assistance communities
will find it difficult
that's why we need to step and enable
and empower and work with our
communities to make that happen
we've been here before we've talked to
lots of different communities about
taking on our play assets
before many communities don't want
that responsibility if i'm honest um so
we're gonna have to work
and and like i say capacity build and
reassure
and do all of those sorts of things and
that's why partly i think the stress the
strategy is a
longer term document rather than a
simple one or two year action plan of
how we will
simply extricate ourselves from play in
rural communities that's not what we're
intending to do
it's about a bigger developer sort of
community development piece
that takes time it takes time to get
these communities in the right places to
accept the responsibility for some of
these things
it's not so difficult for the bigger
town councils but some of the smaller
rural
parishes is it's a big thing well sean
wouldn't you agree we do need a budget
for maintenance
a separate budget from engines and play
spaces
i i i would agree that we need a budget
for
maintenance and place bases yeah i mean
whether it needs to be separate from the
responsive maintenance yeah it's just
because we'll never see anything
otherwise
it needs to be on the financials on page
11.
well you also got the financials on page
20. yeah i mean that's the only
indication of what
is being spent on is on page 26 i think
it was
yeah okay so
i mean we're i mean chair i'm i'm i i'm
i don't accept what sean said about the
asset transfers but there's a lot and um
i don't want to
hash over the past but northern were
made to jump jump through
so many hoops over the westward old part
one
and so much misinformation and we're
talking about the old council now anyway
so i don't wanna i don't wanna go over
all that but we do need a simple
straightforward
way uh it doesn't have to be sold at
best value or anything
there's no best value in these sites as
they are at present
i mean you know i feel ashamed of us
when i look at some of these
sites okay i mean going back to the
situation i mean
the western whole situation was was
quite difficult
and uh was fraught with difficulties um
for many reasons actually and that's
still raw in
particular counselors who served at the
end of the last term
and we'll remember the difficulties we
got into that and the balances that had
to go through that
and it goes right back to i think carson
newton about um
back there at the beginning about trying
to have a direction
but what we're driven back to all the
time given the diversity when i look at
the map of where all these play areas
are
everywhere is unique to its own
situation and and
what we're driven to eventually is is
that we want to do the very best we can
with the resources we've got for the
children in our area
and um to to my mind
i mean where we are there is very little
here that i would want to change in
pages 9-29
um and i would you know okay it does
appear slightly woolly
um in some respects with the with the
length but there's nothing there that is
enormous that i would like to change but
i would listen to others
um and this feeling coming through for
the committee councilor langford
thank you um i'm just wondering
going back to the point i made earlier
is on page
um page 22 when it mentions the working
group
i feel that i would like a bit more of
um a structure to that bit about saying
exactly what the purpose of the working
group will be
so for instance i mean maybe this is too
much information i don't know but i feel
i would like to see you know
the aim of the working group is to and
then a list sort of something like
um you know reassess the parts obviously
adrian mentioned that they needed to
you know they need to be assessed again
and then look at which need urgent
attention
which should be handed over and how that
is going to take place
which could and one thing they could
look at is which could be removed
because some of the small ones as i
mentioned in my email before that some
of the small ones maybe
and what there isn't there is any sort
of survey of how much some of these
parts are used but maybe some of the
very small ones
could be replaced by sort of
child-friendly landscaping as opposed to
equipment
um for others that aren't transferred
um what is going to be done for those
um to upgrade them or help to maintain
them um
and then the system of of supervision
you know of inspecting and the ongoing
maintenance and i agree with councillor
that i would like to see a specific
uh play area maintenance budget
and i actually would like to see as well
a possible standard which is mentioned
in there for things like
fencing and benches and bins and
flooring
but maybe that's too specific but
reading the document
that would have helped me see exactly
what
um is going to happen thank you
can i just ask you for clarity account
sir langford then go back to 22
a working group do you see that wholly
as
officer led or would you want to see
some counselor input
in in the the wording there um
i just think it's a bit um
this group include members from various
teams including
you know that bit there it says that i
mean
i just feel it's not specific enough
about exactly who's on that group
and i mean i don't mind if there's
councillors on it or not they've
obviously got to be people who
who are able to get work done quickly i
don't think council is necessarily
uh maybe the lead on leisure but um
or maybe the play champion but i mean
it's really the people who
can act on things quickly you know if
there's been a report of damage to a
park
you know what is going to happen i know
that's very tiny thing i i mean more
general
exactly what the purpose of the working
group is going to be
i i'd feel more comfortable if that was
there
uh more precise is what you're saying
yeah yeah okay from
um
as financially possible this group
include members of various teams of
economic planning this group will also
search as various chefs and charities on
well could we just add the sentence
there
um to say that it speeds
or expedites delivery of our play areas
and leave it at that would that satisfy
that clause there so langford if we add
that one sentence
together maybe i'm maybe i'm being too
nitpicking and maybe if this is just a
strategic document maybe that kind of
thing shouldn't be in there
but i i kind of i kind of wanted more
more of a plan as to exactly what this
working group would
would do that's all i'm saying but maybe
sean or ladies and gentlemen
yeah mr topham first of all please yeah
i'm still a bit unclear about
implementation pathways and going back
to
what sean was just saying that previous
experience suggests that a lot of
smaller and perhaps rural parishes are
reluctant to take on play areas
do we have any recent or current
information about
which parachutes and towns might be
interested
and bearing in mind just what uh
councillor langford's just said about
alternative approaches to play areas
do we have any information about or is
there any idea of
starting to talk with local accounts
other local
smaller councils about what they would
be interested in doing
would they want to go the full monty and
take it all on and
fund it or would they like to have a
discussion about how best to
implement the play strategy in their
particular area
so i feel this rather lucky you know
it'd be helpful if there's any
more recent information about that sean
can you respond yeah of course i can
share this fine i think what we're
delving into is almost the the unknown
in many respects
what we're hoping for you to do is set a
sort of strategic direction that we
would then go and work out how to
deliver if i'm really honest
and and then it so you we want you to
say the ambition is that we work with
our communities
and wherever possible where they want to
seek ownership we try and find a way to
make that happen because that's in the
best interest of those communities
i don't know which communities that will
be i don't know how much that's going to
cost in which individual play area
where those discussions are yet to be
had but what we need is for you to tell
us
that that's how you think it's best to
work with our communities to develop
play and that
will then help us when we put together
our business plans and our action plans
and all the stuff that we do on a day to
day
that will later come through and be
monitored through the qbr as i was
talking about earlier on so
we're sort of almost getting into the um
i i don't i don't necessarily think this
document needs to say
which play area how much it's going to
cost any of those things
it tells i want you to tell us what you
want us to watch
if may i come back on that chair please
yes then mr topham
yes thank you sean that's exactly what i
think
your first sentence was exactly what i
think i was sort of tentatively trying
to recommend
that the strategy should be part of the
strategy
engaging with local communities
particularly the smaller
less well-funded or less confident ones
and find out exactly what they want and
what they're prepared to put into it
thank you that's one of my
recommendations chair
right counselor hodson thank you very
much chair
um i think most strategies always
contain a part which is
aspirational i've been i won't say
surprise because i was aware of it
that we do have communities without any
play provision at all
for children and it seems to be a bit of
a geographical
lottery of where you live whether you
get
to even be part of this debate
i think when we're consulting with
communities
we really ought to consider what
provision
uh somebody mentioned about um
making sure that in our agreements with
developers we do
ensure that when they're building new
housing
we're getting adequate play provision
but there are going to be places which
just simply don't have any access at all
and quite a large community of children
so i would like to see somewhere in this
document
in um the parts where we're consulting
with our parishes to see
what they'd be prepared to do to invite
and give a voice to those parishes like
your own
um mr chairman and to rosary
to say what their communities would like
to see in the future
and how torridge not to provide directly
but can support and help their
development of the play area
it might be the assignment of one of
your pieces of green land
uh outside areas i don't know but i
think we ought to contain
something it's a play strategy for all
the children
in torridge not just those who are
fortunate to live in an area where there
is something
thank you thank you very much indeed so
having heard all the comments coming
through
the balance between clearer more concise
but picking up the comment that we need
to keep to the strategy
we've had a good discussion let's now
come to a point is there anything
that you would put in in the various
sections in pages 11
to 29 that would alter
the direction of what we have before us
so we come to a point we've had our
discussion
what would you put in in the various
places
from pages 11 to 29 that then
would give that direction and i'm
talking about the overall strategy
strategic direction now um that gives
direction
um to make our future decisions upon
and we have president newton
thanks chair um i just wonder
um when we discussed it before
we we accepted that this was
a much wider issue than just looking
at distinct little play areas uh
normally within urban air within urban
areas
um and indeed on page
nine um we have all the other areas that
we
asked to be included um parks natural
areas immunity
um etc um
is this strategy just going to
acknowledge them by listing them or
actually is it going to be
inclusive of those in bringing the whole
lot together
um some of my
um rural areas
don't have play areas because they have
footpaths
um and and other green space that
that substitutes or is a natural area
for kids to play
um i just wonder whether we're bringing
that in more than just
putting a checklist of of other
other areas of of recreation or or or
space
okay yeah is that sean's up for the
appendices to pick up all these areas at
the back
from a to g uh
it can be checked i mean in in answer to
some of um
council newton's points i think there
are other strategies that pick up
the management of some of those other
spaces and and topics if you know what i
mean and it's to make sure that this
this document is aligned with those
other documents
that we wouldn't want to be setting a
document and i
i mean i'll ask adrian if he's got any
comment in a second because he's been
much more involved in the actual putting
together of the strategy here than i
have been but
um i'm aware that there's been
discussions with planning policy
if you like around the green spaces and
and and pitch provision and things like
that so
this this document isn't a stand alone
um
adrian did you did you have anything to
comment on that no
not really it was just i mean our
initial response to the
to the the first draft if you like
um that was provided for us um
like i said it didn't have any clear
direction so that was our conversation
of trying to
make it a little bit more direct aimed
at our play areas and not really
because those open spaces are very well
recognized in the green infrastructure
strategy
and how they're protected and various
bits like that
i mean i mean you know ian's very much
the expert on that on those bits and we
have a
play pitch strategy for all our sporting
um
uh clubs and everything as well and it
was we we really wanted to direct it
just at the play areas to try and make
that a little bit more clear like we're
discussing now
so um that's kind of why those bits got
taken out if i'm honest
okay yeah i'm just coming back on that
adrian if i can
actually just thinking further and my my
recall
is um um i've just had another birthday
so
my recall gets less but the um
um thinking back to our discussion last
time
actually it was the knowledge of those
other
areas to inform us with regard to what
the lay down of
of play areas should be and so it was a
the discussion was that in order to
put the current list of play
areas into context of were we covering
the the the the and meeting the need
adequately um what what what else was
out there
and what was around them and and i think
the
the discussion was more in that in that
context in fact that
that all of those things needed to be
looked at together when it came to
deciding where play areas were needed et
cetera et cetera
so um yeah i hear that um thank you
coach langford
yeah thank you just a question really um
if
um um for those parks that
um local communities don't want to take
on
presumably torridge will still make a
commitment
to um try and maintain them the best
they can
um i'm not sure if that should be
spelled out
somewhere in this and and i'm i would
love to add a word on page 25
where it says please note this is it
right near the top it says please note
this is a commitment to support where
possible
and not to directly fund each play area
with capital capital funding
i would love to add the word necessarily
so please note this is a commitment to
support where possible and not
necessarily to directly fund each play
area with capital funding
because otherwise i i feel it reads a
little bit
as we can't afford to fund these parks
so we're going to try and asset
you know pass them over to local
communities as much as we possibly can
and it's not totally clear to me that
we're making a commitment
to to keep funding any that don't get
taken on by local communities if
if um if that wording isn't there just
say can you just say the
the wording again in that uh well people
may not agree but basically i would just
want to add word
it's like it it's just the sort of
second line down please note this is a
commitment to support where possible
and not to i want to add and not
necessarily to directly fund each play
area with capital funding
okay here comment any objections to that
i haven't any objections to that but
uh just on that point can i i've got
christopher leather and christopher
newton waiting here just the present
moment
are we making it too easy i mean if it's
uh
if it's up we desire
in the ideal situation to
pass the smaller play areas
into town and parish uh control
for they to look after because we
believe that
that is a better way of running those
those areas then we don't want to sort
of
offer people too easier a way out of of
that
of that desire what we desire
um surely otherwise they're going to
turn around and say oh well we're not
going to do that because they're going
to carry on funding it um
i i entirely hear where you're coming
from but um
i think this is a strategy of saying
what what do we
what ideally what do we want to happen
well ideally
we want actually the smaller ones to
pass
into local community control
um sure this is where we're going to get
now and because a strategy is overall
going back to
officer kearney and all uh comments
about
we need a strategy in place here okay um
and we can draw and try to be more
precise if we want to
um but but the situation is we have to
sometimes i think
turn it around and say we want to make
the very best we can with the resources
that we have
and let that be our strategy and that is
where we then come to the direction of
sorting out where these play areas go at
a future time down the line
because if we put too many um
stipulations no at the beginning
and we're going to go through this
document no point by point
and i go back to what i said we've come
to a point now
what would we want to change is there
anything specific
i hear the word necessary that went in
there
um i i understand you've got a few words
coming to
but are we not getting into a situation
now
that we are trying to predict when the
next play area comes up for renewal
and the community shows interest we have
to stick by a strategy what if we say
and turn it around the other way
and say look we are doing our very best
we can
represent our communities to achieve the
best for our
children then maybe that is the best way
we can achieve the strategy that we're
going to go down into and i just wonder
if we can keep it at that level in and
keeping by what we have here or making
or not making too many alterations from
that point of view
um counselor leather
thank you chair well i'll just go back
to page 22 that council langford
mentioned
the working group if there's a working
group i think it most certainly should
involve
councillors um and cheryl would be
obviously on that as well but then over
the page when we look at
the suggestion about having play
champions
that's a bit not very clear i mean i
would expect the play champions to be
counsellors as well
and i'm a bit disappointed at each main
area of biddeford holes rather in
torrent and what's wrong with northern
then
second largest area in torridge i think
we
needed we need now to focus on our
strategies guys just
um not to get down into the individual
areas
that torridge is a dollar the strategy
is to start with going out to the
passion town councils and asking
if they've got if they've got areas play
areas in their
parishes do they want to take them over
from tories that's
where i would start with a strategy
and having a maintenance budget set when
we do the budget this year
we need a separate maintenance budget
we've got to start addressing
the lack of provision in some of these
play areas whether they get transferred
eventually
or not that means a strategy
keep it simple well that's what i'm
trying to do
so that we can focus our minds here now
to come to that sort of
a a direct strategy that we come forward
and and we're going to get driven down
into minutiae if we're not careful and
lose what is the overall strategy
of where tord should be coming to um and
i'm trying to
find it's you've got the document here
before where would you insert or take
something out as a committee um in this
situation
to to put the strategy forward to go
forward to cnr that's where i'm coming
from
um and if there is something that you
would want to put in now
um i don't want to go through page by
page but if there is something burning
that each of you feel which would go
into the strategy
then let's vote on it and be clear on it
either it goes in or it comes out
and i would like to see some
propositions coming forward
you've got the document here that we
should be looking at bear in mind i
don't want to get into the minutiae
of the little individual here is there
what will she hasn't got or what litmup
hasn't got
but the strategy that we should be
facing of where target goes to the
future and if you want to put a sentence
in
about uh we should be consulting we can
put that sentence in if you want to
propose that counselor
well i will do when we get to making any
proposals a
phil topham mentioned a similar one to
mine that
first thing he mentioned for himself is
that we do contact the parish and town
councils
before before you decide anything else
to see what
what there is interest from them in
taking on players and
we are talking about the play areas of
36.
we're not talking about football pitches
or rugby pitches or other kinds of play
areas like that
we're talking about the what's in the
report here the 36 areas
sure can you're next on the list can you
thank
you
i just wanted to just sort of i don't
know make a point really in that
we don't you know part of the need for
this strategy is for us to better use
our
resources in the recognition that we
don't have enough money
to maintain all of our play areas to the
standard
that would be expected is tip-top
standard we can't
do that unless you as members through
the normal budgeting process
de-prioritize something else and
prioritize play
you know that in the past has been you
know there's been big discussions about
budget
and we've got to where we are um
so i think it's it's not really for this
strategy to be making recommendations
that you create budgets whatever
you might recommend to cnr that they
consider that
but does it that get included within
this strategy i think the strategic
intent of the document
is what this is about how it's delivered
is then the consideration of community
and resources if they make budget
available and
and then your officer teams once you've
got an adopted strategy and a budget
how do we make it happen as you want it
to happen but
you know ultimately we we don't have the
money
to keep all these barriers in tip-top
conditions so we've got to think about
where we concentrate our resources
on those sort of um flagship play areas
if you want
and then how we work with our
communities to make sure that they get
the best out of those spaces
and in some instances that will mean
decommissioning and closing them down
because they're just simply
either not valued by that community or
they're not affordable
there are some tough decisions to be
made around some of these things but
they don't all have to be made in this
document
uh mr topham yeah well my proposal is
under section three what does tory james
to do
what page is that mr tobin sorry well i
don't know i've got
a small letter it's page 17 and big
letters it's page 22.
thank you for the expect again very
beginning of section three
so there's one statement the play area
strategy outlines the plan et cetera et
cetera
well i was suggesting that having a
second
strategic aim there about aiming to
engage with local communities about the
future of their play areas
particularly the ones in rural towns or
small towns and parishes
which it may be difficult for torridge
to support as fully as they would like
along those lines is that okay that
would be
sounds quite a good proposition given
the discussion that we have had
um would you propose a an addition there
would you make another
proposition mr topham yeah i'd make it a
preposition
i think i would take a nap
sorry uh sh i've got no hands in front
of me i think i heard charleston
uh voice there i said that i'd second
that
we've got lots of people second of the
uh mr tom can you just say what you said
again please
this is being recorded
um yeah okay so the first name is as
written
and the second aim is that the the torah
district council will
aim to engage with local communities
particularly those with
with with small counts to parish
councils and town councils
about supporting the future maintenance
and development of their play areas
oh god i haven't forgotten that that's
excellent
okay committee we've heard the proposed
then from uh
mr topham um and seconded by
councillor newton and councillor coddle
honking so they're all in queue there to
get their second in that point of view
okay any amendments yeah
yes there's another i'm still a bit
concerned about this ten years time
for some of this and the rest of that
opening
paragraph there seems to be kicking the
can down the road a bit when it talks
about
when finances can finances can allow
and sean's just mentioned about there's
no money well
it's a case of how you allocate
resources in the in in the council
and also there are loans that the
council can apply for if they want to
so i don't like the fact that we seem to
be always saying there's no money there
there's no money there there always
seems to be money for some things but
not for others okay
and it's been it's been a long long time
many years
that we've allowed this state of affairs
to
to happen to our play areas and i don't
want it
to wait another 10 years before we get a
proper resolution of these problems with
them
i i okay let's go back to where we were
we've had the proposition for mr topham
and the second by councillor newton um
and uh coaster carlo honkin and there
was the flavor that's coming through
from listening to the meeting
um there was a real wish to engage with
local communities
um is there any amendment to that um
any other proposal coming on the table
to that
i'd see no blue hands so we have a
proposal and a seconder that we add that
second paragraph on a page either
bottom 22 or 17 smaller
to that what does torridge aim to do so
we have an overall strategy coming in
that is then engaging with local
communities
so i asked uh mary's and mary if you
could take a vote please
okay council coddle honking for
council afford four
council harding or
councillor hawkins
councillor pennington mr topham
mr topham oh thank you
yeah unanimous thank you no question
leather
picking up your previous point because
this is what cars aim to do
10 years is there something else you
would put in there now we are now at the
stage that we've had a discussion
is there something that you would like
to see in this document
that you can make a proposition now that
we could put forward to cnr well part of
the
part of the strategy should be to
establish a maintenance budget for our
play areas
and that should be part of the strategy
and it's not mentioned and i'd like
to make that a proposal that we that we
do
in the strategy establish a maintenance
budget right
play areas then is there you've heard
a maintenance budget to be allocated
is there a seconder to your to catch
another here
i'll second that okay so langford the
second did it
any other propositions to to look at
that ten-year question
uh councillor connor honkin oh it's just
i didn't know i'm a bit cautious about
this because if we are
transferring them to different parish
councils then obviously the budget would
change wouldn't it i don't i don't know
if we should have about
that number in the
it will be evolving as as we work things
out and
transfer them well cheryl you don't have
to spend the budget
i mean it if we've set if we set a
budget
for maintenance which we've not got now
that should be part of the strategy
but if we do transfer pretty quickly
some of these play areas of course there
won't be a drain on the budget in that
although we may have to replace some
equipment before we transfer
but we haven't got any budget now to
draw them
okay any other points from any other
counselors on main getting a maintenance
budget we've had a proposition from
councillor leather
and the second for councillor um
to put this into the aim that torres
does any
any other comment before i go to the
vote
no okay then quit mary if we can um
take a vote on adding that
into the aims that the maintenance
budget is put in place
okay councillor cottle hanging four
council afford four
newton or councillor pennington
again strangely enough but that's the
way the committee works and
uh we that we ask that we put into the
strategy before it goes to cnr
mr topham
for cutting in oh right okay it was very
bad manners i
apologize apology accepted right i
apologize absolutely
yeah that was eight four one against one
against okay so that's sorted you've got
that direction there
sean and adrian are you okay with that
yeah more happy thank you yeah thank you
right any other additions you want to
make to these pages
um that's committee you've got a blue
hand here from councillor leather
check check thank you can we remove
the top of that first paragraph over the
next 10 years
so it just reads the play area strategy
outlines a plan to upgrade or replace
all playgrounds
yeah we shouldn't set a time limit right
so you proposed it
yeah second is sheriff caller honking
counselor coddle honking
yeah i'll secretly make
yes mr newton newton um
depending on whether council another is
is happy but
can we add upgrade replace or transfer
all playgrounds because a key
potential action is to transfer some of
them
um rather than if we say upgrade or
replace well that
suggests that we're doing that you know
that's all with torridge well
that isn't that that is not the whole
picture surely
yeah i'm very happy with that chair
thanks for that cancer newton yeah
i'm very happy with that so are you
happy to uh
amend as well cheryl yeah yeah sounds
good
okay uh and you all know what that
proposition is guys
so can we go to the vote
mary sorry councillor
honking oh councillor ford
four councillor harding
or councillor hawkins
or councillor langford
councillor leather or
councillor newton four
councillor pennington yeah
mr topham oh
yes unanimous thank you
right any further wishes to
add or take away we have
counselor coddle honking um i
just about what was mentioned previously
by dawn carney about
at the beginning of the strategy
something
um signed by councillor james and
steve hurst or or what's i don't know
what what does the committee want there
to go there
do we want the forward to go in
at the beginning
what well okay because we've kind of
spoke about it but nothing was proposed
so i don't know what is actually
happening with that
that's right i have a proposition chair
if you want
then make your proposition question
newton uh chair
i propose that um a forward
is written by the lead member
and that the document at the front is
signed by the chief executive and the
leader
yeah simple
the secondary is that okay
oh checking that i'm gonna send it
forward
sure did you make a proposition before i
i lose track here or whatever
i wanted to find out what was going on
with it because okay
proposition so christian newton you have
made a proposition
which i think has getting a seconder
from councillor ford
correct correct okay i'm correct at this
point
um so therefore we have a proposition
and a
seconder um any other
amendments or propositions here there's
a hand up from councillor ford
is that uh still wanted to add something
or other hand
no but very briefly on that score um
um just something nothing to do with
this but
what would be interesting to know for
the future
is actually who does our maintenance
because obviously outside contractors
um and that's always concerned me about
anything to do with play equipment it's
a bit like
undertakers and vets it's almost like
they've got the right to try what they
like
thank you okay here anyway we go back to
the proposition
um coaching remind me the proposition
which was seconded by
councillor ford my proposition would be
that the document at the front
is signed off by the chief executive
or right the other way around by the
leader and the chief executive
and uh a forward to the document
is written by the uh lead member
the good councillor carl hunkin so she
can't vote in this
because she's got a just an interest in
that she's got to write it so
[Laughter]
i i don't think it's a pecuniary
interest so i think she's
okay from that point of view okay we've
got a clear proposition and a secondary
can mary can we take a vote so that we
can
know where we're going please cancel a
coddle honking
so can i vote for or not
yes you can cheryl and there'll be me up
before the standards if you're in
trouble
so that's recorded
i've got an interest because i've got a
little boy and one on the way
well i forgot to say that okay
i'm glad uh this is council ford uh i
will be voting for
uh and i'm glad carl hunken god bless
her has mentioned that
personal interest i don't think it's a
prejudicial one um let's hope she
doesn't end up with a football team god
bless her
no i don't think that would be happening
okay can we keep moving guys please
council afford four
council harding for
councillor hawkins or
councillor langford for
council leather or
councillor newton or
councillor pennington or mr tobin
hey unanimous that's excellent thank you
mary
okay any further there's burning issues
you want to add to make sure it goes
into this document
i see no hand so i'm going to move on
quickly
good um we then
look at no sorry one thing i was just
going to raise i apologize for
forgetting because i was just
sharing the role um it picks up the
situation in victoria park
um and i was reading about and we i had
a
um somebody that was injured in victoria
park play area
in my ward i wanted to follow up and
i think there was mention of drug
paraphernalia in there
on page 103 of the
the report and it was in the same area
that i knew
there was an injury to a youngster can i
just ask
um about health and safety um
do we record and have we have a policy
of recording
um were things like obviously the
offensive articles in the middle of that
page
have we got a policy in place that makes
sure that we
are giving clear guidance to people of
what to do
when there is injury or offensive things
within a play area
can i ask our officers um if there is a
policy or if we've got actions
that we can take
yeah yes i can respond to that if you
want so we we have daily inspections of
our players
so that's undertaken and any defects or
incidents
um of drug paraphernalia things like
that
um they're recorded and obviously we
keep those records for insurance
purposes
okay no further questions that it
answers the question
from from my point of view all on on
that matter and the other one i had in
place was i know that
counselor goth brought uh a nose emotion
about disabled
uh use of play area and i don't see
any equality issue here about disabled
have i got that
wrong um just guide me officers
if i've missed that along in this policy
i'm pretty sure it isn't there um i'll
let adrian answer it
adrian yeah yeah i believe there is
there is a tiny bit but it does need to
be clearer that's that's a great um
chair there um it was something that um
i think of your counselor called honking
or or langford raised it in there
in their notes to me um about making it
exploring more opportunities for um
for four disabilities if you like for
our play areas so that is something that
you know i'm certainly aware of and
happy to
make clear within the document right
thank you very much indeed for that
uh um answer adrian so that has just it
feels like we don't need to take a vote
on that so you you'll pick up that in
in your your future comment okay
um do we need to do anything on the
pages page by page on on the individual
areas because i think we're talking
about strategy not the individual play
areas
unless somebody's got something burning
on on the following pages
uh counselor leather
thank you chair no i'm still on the
strategy
sorry sorry because another yeah glarion
strategy
age 27 yeah i mentioned it earlier about
play champions and i see
it's uh proposed in there that it's
members of staff
it will be these these champions okay
again it's officers are not members
involvement as
the working group was at the start and
i do regret the fact that it doesn't
mention northern that mentions benefit
holdsworthy and torrington
but not northern northern second largest
area in torridge
population wise i appreciate uh
the main area okay i have no objection
i mean please indicate committee by hand
if you'd
objected northern being added to
biddeford hosley and torrington
nobody's putting her hand up so can we
add norms
i just wonder whether there should be
these champions should be
elected members rather than officers
well make your proposition uh i'd like
to hear what other members
okay uh let's have uh other members
views
and we have cursor harding
yeah thank you chair um yeah i think
it'd be a good idea having um
um councillors um as well as um
um paid mem
services and what you want to call them
um to be involved i think you know
it's a it'll be a good thing especially
so you would like to see
officers and members forming part of
the group yes okay
and council newton yeah
um i have to say i'm i'm not hugely
excited by the whole play champion area
anyhow
um however to my mind
it could be officers or members i don't
think it's
it's specifically one or other it's
whoever's best for the
best for the role um but i'll i'll
withdraw from discussing it further
because i obviously have a
um okay
not finishing a sentence like okay yeah
right cursor leather
it's either a case it'll be drawing that
paragraph completely i think
and and having the memory involvement in
the working group
but i do feel that this strategy does
need
besides offices it needs member
involvement otherwise it's
just the office is running the strategy
and i think members should be involved
in
delivering this strategy chair so we
either
take the play i won't we don't want to
overload it with membership of things
and whether they are necessary these
play champions i'm not so sure
i agree to to some extent with council
newton there i mean
i'm not overly enthused i don't know if
members of staff would be to be honest
so i think we i propose we shift that
completely out of the
strategy but i would like member
involvement in the working group
definitely
i'll make that a proposal chair just
take it back to where the working group
what page was the working group on again
22
22. thank you working group working
group working okay yeah so we're looking
at pages 20
yeah both on 22 actually you got the
play champions on page 27
big print and page 22 big print um so
yeah you got that
so let me be clear where you're coming
from counselor leather
working group you're looking at um yeah
i would much prefer that there were
members of
of elected members on that working group
and that would be up to the group
leaders to to discuss with their members
who they'd like
to go on that and really take out the
play champions a bit altogether i just
think it's a bit of a
i do agree really with councillor newton
it's it doesn't
enthuse me very much though and i don't
know if members of staff want to be
bothered with that they've got
enough on the plate without volunteering
to to do that so look at that
wish to discuss councillor ford yeah
following on from that
um basically i would like to remind um
cancer that very often a camel was a
horse put together by a committee
now basically we do need cancer level is
absolutely right
what we need here is actually to get it
refined you need a working group you
need probably
i would suggest two counselors maybe
caught one king langford people that
have got expertise and got great
i would say energy in this area you know
we've got to utilize
what we've got like you know it's like
any business or
a football team you have a fullback you
have a striker you have right people
right jobs
these people are committed they you know
they they are well versed with it
you want to get a working group i would
suggest i don't know how you're going to
do that
you don't want any more than six people
you want two members
maybe four officers maximum you know we
gotta decide on that somehow
to actually drive this forward because
there's no good having 15
20 people discussing this you've got to
get it down to the nitty gritty
the right skills right people with the
right drive i think
the flavor is because you think there
should be member involvement in the
workings
yes definitely okay mr topham
hello yeah thank you chad um yeah i i'm
not so keen on the idea of the uh the
champions really
um but i do wonder whether the working
group if you're going to have one core
group
sort of managing play strategy whether
it would be worth inviting bearing in
mind the strategic aim of
involving uh other councils whether it
might be
worth involving inviting one or two
people from those councils to be part of
it
i i take the point that you can have too
many people in such a group
but given that part of the strategy is
to engage with
other parishes and town councils maybe
to have them involved in the working
group in some way would be
advantageous so you're saying members
from other councils
what do you mean by members from other
councils mr topham
exactly that counsellors from uh okay
because they will be the first port of
call when you start talking to them
about the future of their play areas
okay now go back to council nether again
then to refine this
are you going to make a proposition
leather that should we remove the
paragraph on
page on play chat yeah if you look at
the audience and take
the whole paragraph yeah because if you
look at the bullet points actually some
of those are what a working group
group will be doing in any event and
then we put in that we asked for
for two members to be uh
two elected members to be involved in
the working group
two and what two tourist councillors two
torch councils two elected torch
councillors to be in and
included in the working group yeah well
i'm just wondering about the groups
we've got what four groups aren't being
told
is it four groups political
political groups they might want a
member from each group to be involved
then
shall we refine it to the leader of
community culture and leisure
which is the role that our president is
doing very well in
and just so the member involvement comes
from that point of view well i take it i
take it for granted that cheryl will be
involved in a working group
i just took that for granted but i think
we well
i think we need at least three councils
in there okay
well what can we then i mean bearing in
mind um
how you would picking up what phil says
how you would
um get parish representatives
on there i don't know really i don't
think
i don't think it would be worthwhile
doing that i mean their input would be
during the consultation with terran
parish councils
they would they they could always come
to that working group
and add anything that they need to if
particularly if they're talking about it
now just as something what the meaning
is about here go just uh
just the i don't think anybody's
opposing we take out the the uh
page the play champion paragraph okay
it's just how we word to to to get
member involvement is that correct
anybody shout that's okay
so yeah sorry shurikon honking
i was just thinking where it says about
the play champions it talks about
having hopefully for different areas so
whether we were to have
a counsellor from a different area on
the working group whether that would
work better
rather than the political groups well i
think that you're driving down
unless my per maybe the committee might
think differently
um i think we need a policy statement
here
uh a strategy where we're driving
through sean you've had your hand up for
a minute i'm sorry i've not
brought you in thank you chair i just
wanted to really clarify what the role
of the working group was in my mind
it wasn't to sort of create another
committee it isn't really
um anything formal i don't see that it
would be a zoom meeting that was
officially minuted
i think this is something that basically
it's a group of officers
with a member or two whatever you'd like
i mean i'm not saying that members
shouldn't be involved don't get me wrong
um but it's not a big formal thing it's
it's a group of people to devise how we
deliver the strategy
and then see it through um right yeah so
it i i don't want to
make an industry at this so i guess
i appreciate what you're saying sean i
hear your message tea time is coming
um okay so so so
uh play champion paragraph i think is
going to go
okay from what i'm feeling from the
committee show your hand up again
yeah i didn't know if we could just keep
it simple and say
counselors who are passionate about play
spaces
to be part of the working group i think
you take a risk
you can certainly put it that way i just
wonder whether we could uh various teams
including
elected members economic development
planning property and finance and we
just left it putting in
elected members and the council can
decide how to do that at a future stage
but we
do make sure elected representation is
put into the working group
i wonder if that would satisfy the
situation
yeah yeah yeah okay
so what this position is and i think it
came from christopher leather to start
with
um so i i would like him to take a lead
i think that was the right counselor
leather looking at me notes here
yeah was to take the play champions out
okay
and to add in the uh
second sentence of the working groups on
page 22
bottom 17 top this group include members
from various
including elected members comma economic
development
planning blah blah blah yes yeah yeah
i'll second that
second councillor ford so we have a
problem any other propositions
none good go to the vote mary please
sure counselor for
councillor ford or
councillor harting for council hawkins
or councillor langford
councillor leather or
councillor newton or
councillor pennington yeah mr topham
oh thank you unanimous jeff
thank you mary thank you committee so
any
others before we move on i see no blue
hands so i'm going to move on quickly
yeah um we've got the uh attachment of
each of the play areas anybody has any
burning comments
that they want to make about it are we
hand the hand up coaster langford
yeah can i just ask sean and adrian
please as i understand
it the fort in victoria park is part of
the
um as capital there is capital money set
aside
to a deal with that next year i believe
um is that just the thought area or does
that include the sandpit
and the playground for little ones
chair i think i can partially answer
that i think
it's just the thought but i will seek
clarification and email it around if you
like
sure okay and sean sorry just on that we
are meeting
on um tuesday with with helen bond um
unfortunately
leaving us we have she's doing a we're
doing a bit of a handover meeting
next monday or tuesday so and that's on
my list to discuss
so we can confirm that going forward as
well no problem
thank you all right no more for the blue
hands
um just one question for me on page 83
sean
and adrian um it's tp32 kingsmeat drive
and it's the one excellent um play area
that we have in the report
um i see andrew wait has been involved
but he's no longer with us
um um obviously he's got a gift
um can he has he passed on on to eight
the
adrian um what what what he did so well
at the kingsmead drive to get an
excellent score there
no i don't know the answer george
okay that's just an interesting i i mean
uh uh
i see adrian andrew is put there from
that point of view
okay and lastly dependencies you will
deal with those dependencies
just tell us shawn what is going to go
into these appendices
so that we are aware of what will be
before the committee
uh before cnr
adrian might be a better place to answer
that one
uh i'm not
unfortunately uh now with the impedances
that i've i've currently got on the
document that is
um it's just those are based around the
green infrastructure
um the play and pitch strategy and and
that pitch can
pitch you can sorry the play area
condition survey
uh friends of the earth but no um but
but nothing else additional that i was
aware of
putting in there sorry okay we're not
listing all the other
play areas around torres or anything
like that or the other play areas
um linked to the social landlords
um i'm happy to happy to explore that
and
and do so if that's what members would
like um i know that there was some um i
think debate last time about
and actually some of the documents were
so uh
trying to pull these documents together
we weren't entirely sure what was where
anymore and
difficult so actually just easier to
take out
let's leave that to further work in
progress and park that for the time and
hand up there from councillor coddle
honking
yeah it was just about kingsmeade and
the answer to that is king's need park
fundraising group um so they got
together
and it was because of them they helped
kelp street
community group and they helped um
burwood
park helping hands so they were kind of
champions in themselves in
inspiring and helping the other
community groups
to raise money but obviously they worked
with andrew waite
as well so they work with
there's a model of good practice that we
could all learn from i suspect in your
players for the future
is there any other questions that we
have a committee that you
want to ask of of our excellent officers
any questions
yeah please yeah yeah one for adrian
please it's not a question it's just a
uh something i see right back at the the
beginning where
you list play area locations on page 12
or 17 whichever one you're looking at
tp 19 clinton hall you've put in red
because you can't find it i suspect that
is
merton yes
uh yeah that's correct i had there was
two on there that
um that looked a bit dubious to me and
not even in our areas so
um going forward um what i did what i
actually did
is to erase any sort of um
well we're planning to take that out
actually just to make sure that
they are all in alignment with what we
have for our 36 for those that aren't
there
so that one that one there clinton hall
if it is matt and that is in our area
correct yeah i was well i
because it said i camped and actually
yeah ignore it
that that's a postcode address but but
um
bizarrely because um but it's merton and
that's run
by the parish council because they fund
race and they've got a new play area
there now as well
so it's not owned by porridge i'm pretty
sure
okay one more hand from our country
honking your hands still blue
is that you said all you want to say
chair all the
acoustic leather he's not gonna but
on that uh on that page page
little page 12 large number 17.
yeah tp37 for adrian's benefit
ridgeway court is the one that northern
have taken over yeah which is at the
start of the things and is
sean's been an excellent play area okay
lovely thank you for coming there and my
only one further comment is that um
the um colour scheme on this page
15 and small print 20 large print
can you have a different color yellow
for tarrington so that we can
because you think tarrington may be an
excellent play area when it's actually
um satisfactory and i just wondered if
you had two different shades of yellow
but that's just
nitpicking really um i want to thank
everybody um
for all their work um thank you for the
committee thank you particularly to
adrian
sean um and the officers and thank you
for your contributions this afternoon
it's
really somewhere to go forward do we
need to vote stacy
on the recommendation on the report um
that we put forward now what we've
discussed to cnr do we need to take a
vote on that just
guide me yes chair yeah
right then so we have the the uh
recommendation and you go back to page
five
uh sean you've got your hand up
sure sorry chair that was just to remind
you that you needed to take a vote but
that's just been done
[Laughter]
right okay then we're back on the page
five
and um you're bottom page five you have
the recommendations there you know and
i'm not going to get married to read out
all the
uh things we've requested to to add it
but you know what they are
um can we have a proposition i'll
propose from the chair that before
again a second footwork mary can you
take the vote
yes sure councillor coddle hankin
council report four
councillor harding four
councillor hawkins or
councillor lanford or
councillor leather or
councillor newton or
councillor pennington or
mr tubman or
unanimous jeff thank you very much
everybody thank you mary for going
through all the uh
the uh scribing that you do so well all
the time thank you
thank you officers um for all the work
you're doing and
um look forward to our children
grandchildren
and maybe even great grandchildren great
times in torridge and our player
we have i bet you all good afternoon and
i'll see you in a week's time
when we have a joint meeting so there
you are okay good going
thank you very much everybody